hey 42 here on September the 6th 1992 a
group of moose hunters came across an
old abandoned City boss in the Alaskan
Wilderness it was a pretty odd sight
considering they were almost 30 miles
from the nearest town and nowhere near a
road of any kind but it was also a
welcome one it had been a long day and
the bus represented an opportunity to
spend the night indoors
if you can actually count a rusting gold
boss as indoors anyway the moment the
hunter stepped over the threshold and
entered the vehicle they were hit by a
wall of a foul smelling air so thick
they could practically taste it
this being the Alaskan Bush they first
assumed an animal had just crawled into
the bus and died but then they found a
sleeping bag and inside that the
partially decomposed body of a man the
police arrived on the scene via
helicopter the following morning and
made haste to investigate this most
morbid case this should have been a
tricky one half rotten corpses in the
middle of nowhere and don't give up
their secrets easily or so I'm told but
the officers were in for a pleasant
surprise because beside the body they
found a diary and several undeveloped
rolls of film a record of sorts of the
man's life and what an unusual existence
it turned out to be
you see this body didn't belong to a
grizzled Trapper or a lost hiker but a
24 year old idealist who 'd given up
everything to try and live a simpler
more authentic life and the story of how
he came to die in an old abandoned bus
in the middle of nowhere in Alaska is
one of the most unusual I've ever told
on this channel it begins with a
bigamous marriage and ends with a
Botanical murder mystery and it's either
soaringly uplifting or utterly idiotic
and depressing depending on who you ask
this is the tale of Christopher
McCandless
the man who walked into the wild and
never came back
Christopher was born on February the
12th 1968 in Inglewood California his
father Walt was an aerospace engineer he
worked for NASA and his mother Billy
helped run the family consultancy
business
but don't let this affluent upbringing
fool you life in the McCandless home was
a tale of endless Strife Chris had a
younger sister Karine as well as six
half siblings from his father's first
marriage in 2014 Karine McCandless
published a memoir in which she alleged
that her parents were verbally and
physically abusive both to each other
and to their children after graduating
from high school in 1986 with excellent
grades Chris spent the summer on his
first major solo Adventure his family
had relocated from California to
Virginia when he was still a kid so he
traveled back to his home state to spend
time with his extended family and a few
old friends but during this detour he
made a disturbing Discovery when he was
little his father had often spent time
away from the family home as a
successful businessman you might think
he was simply traveling for work but no
he was spending time in his other family
home you see Walt has still been married
to his first wife when he met Chris's
mother Billy rather than you know get a
divorce or even break things off he
simply split his time between the
families even having children with both
women at the same time Chris would later
discover that he was just three months
older than one of his half-brothers
he was 18 when he found out and it had a
huge impact on him some people have even
suggested that all the other craziness
I'm going to tell you about can be
traced back to that one mud revelation
further education was a chance for Chris
to fly his freaky family nest and he
excelled at Emory University graduating
in 1980 with double honors in history
and anthropology
most people who knew him in those days
expected him to follow a familiar path
start a career make lots of money maybe
have a family
but Christopher McCandless had no
intention of living a conventional life
he saw the expectations of society not
as items on a checklist to be ticked off
one by one but has a straight jacket
designed to Rob us of our freedoms and
stifle our creativity
and so in May 1990 he donated every
penny he owned to Oxfam well over fifty
thousand dollars in today's money and
without telling a Seoul where he was
going or even that he was going
he just left
he spent that first summer crossing the
U.S in his beaten up yellow Datsun
making it as far as Lake Mead before
getting stuck in a flash flood that
wrecked the engine and left him stranded
instead of turning back Chris forged
onwards hiking hitchhiking and riding
freight trains over a two-year spree
traversing the land of the free Chris
built a new life for himself under the
assumed name of Alexander Supertramp it
was an alter ego of sorts a self-made
superhero who's only two Powers were
total freedom and body odor nobody knows
Christopher's exact whereabouts during
that time on the road and what we do
know mostly comes from the memories of
people whose paths he crossed along the
way he spent a few moms working as a
grain operator for a man he met whilst
hitchhiking in South Dakota he lived on
the streets of Las Vegas learned lever
working from a retired Vietnam vet he
grew so attached to Chris he offered to
adopt him as a grandson
he lived in Hermit camps and off-grid
communities
hiked through some of the most
spectacular national parks on planet
Earth and illegally kayaked down the
Colorado River all the way to Mexico
in short he roamed where he pleased
answer to nobody and completely cut
himself off from the usual worries and
expectations of the rest of the world he
had no bills to pay no boss to suck up
to and no requirements Beyond putting
food in his belly and finding a place to
rest his head
he left home in search of freedom and
boy that's exactly what he'd found as
exhilarating as that must have been
it wasn't enough
it was true that Chris was no longer
living by society's rules but he was
still living in society or at least
surrounded by it
and so in early 1992 he ceased his
Carefree wherever the wind takes me
wandering and began puffing his way
purposefully North his goal was the
United States last Great Wilderness a
state that's comfortably bigger than
France Spain and Germany put together
but with less than half a percent of
their combined population
Alaska
it was to be the site of Alexander
supertramp's greatest and final
Adventure on the 28th of April a
Fairbanks electrician called Jim gallion
gave Christopher a lift to the head of
the Stampede Trail
most alaskans know a thing or two about
surviving in the wilderness and Jim was
immediately concerned that Chris didn't
exactly seem to be prepared for a long
spell out in the bush
he had little in the way of Provisions
his rifle lacked the power to easily
take down Alaska's bigger game or its
more dangerous wildlife and his hiking
boots weren't even waterproof he carried
no Compass no snowshoes and very few
tools he didn't even have a map in short
Chris appeared to have none of the gear
and no idea
Jim gallion was right to be concerned
because he would be the last person to
see Christopher McCandless alive
Chris's original plan had been to hike
clear across Alaska until he hit the
Bering Sea but just four days and 30 odd
miles into his journey having forwarded
two rivers and skidded across several
Frozen Beaver ponds he stumbled upon an
abandoned bus that was soon to become
his home and eventually his two
you won't be surprised to hear that life
in the Alaskan Bush was pretty tough the
weather was changeable and often extreme
and food was difficult to come by but
despite the hardships Chris was living
his dream of existing entirely free of
the influence of the outside world
for food he foraged for berries dug up
roots and shot squirrels tarmigan
porcupines and even a moose though he
was unable to preserve this Mighty
mammal so most of the meat spoiled he
survived encounters with bears and
wolves watched herds of caribou crossed
a tiger and spent his downtime reading
classics by Henry David Thoreau Leo
Tolstoy and Nikolai goggle Chris was
clearly a resourceful guy his two years
on the road had proven that but it seems
he'd underestimated just how hard it
would be to live entirely off-grid in
Alaska and whilst his diary shows he was
able to gather a steady stream of food
he simply couldn't get his hands on
enough calories to fuel his body through
the challenging Alaskan days
despite his best efforts slowly but
surely Christopher McCandless was
beginning to weaken
pictures from the undeveloped roles of
film found with his body would later
reveal how thin almost skeletal he
became
he must have recognized the danger he
was in because on day 67 of his Alaskan
Odyssey he decided enough was enough he
packed up his meager belongings said
goodbye to his boss-based Abode and
began hiking back up the Stampede Trail
an incredibly frail Alexander Supertramp
had decided it was time to return to
civilization
two days later he reached the teclanica
river and what he saw made his spine
shiver when he'd crossed this very
stream from the other side at the start
of his journey it was knee-deep and
Placid now swollen by two months of
Summer melt water it had morphed into a
raging torrent of freezing frothing
death
Chris wasn't the strongest of Swimmers
at the best of times but right now that
didn't matter one dime
the love child of Michael Phelps and
Flipper the dolphin couldn't have
crossed that River and lived to tell the
tale
with little of a choice Chris simply
turned around and headed back to the bus
it's hard to imagine just how scared he
must have been as it hit home that he'd
become trapped in this Wilderness but
sometime after he got back to the bus we
have no way of knowing exactly when he
wrote a brief note and posted it to the
door of his makeshift home
it read attention possible visitors SOS
I need your help I am injured near death
and too weak to hike out I am all alone
this is no joke in the name of God
please remain to save me I am out
collecting berries close by and shall
return this evening thank you Chris
McCandless
August question mark
by the time someone finally read those
words Christopher McCandless had been
dead for almost three weeks
in the days and weeks after Chris's
return to the boss his condition
continued to deteriorate his body
growing weaker as he slowly starved to
death
his diary entries during that period
make for some pretty tough reading
Day 94 extremely weak fault of pot seed
much trouble just to stand up starving
great Jeopardy
day 100 made it but in weakest condition
of Life Death looms a serious threat too
weak to walk out have literally become
trapped in the wild no game
nobody knows exactly what Christopher
was going through in those final few
days of his life
but there's no doubt
he knew he was going to die
and yet despite the hunger despite the
hardship despite the loneliness he still
somehow managed to Marvel at the beauty
that was all around him in those final
dying days he took one final
self-portrait in it he's smiling a
beaming smile and waving at the camera
and in his hand he holds a handwritten
note that reads I have had a happy life
and thanked the Lord goodbye and by God
bless all if one of the objectives of
Christopher's trip was to find peace
with this picture I hope we can say that
he truly finally found it
on day 107 the final words in his diary
simply read
beautiful blue berries
six days later on day 113
the entries run out
so far as we know that was the day
Christopher McCandless died
his autopsy would later show that he
weighed just 30 kilograms when he passed
away and his cause of death was ruled to
be starvation that might sound fairly
obvious given the circumstances but
interestingly enough that verdict has
actually been a little controversial in
a decade since you see many people
believe that Chris died not because he
didn't have enough to eat but because he
accidentally ingested some kind of
poison that left him too weak to gather
enough food John krakauer author of into
the wild the book that first brought
Christopher's story to the masses has
spent the last few decades attempting to
prove that the seeds of the wild potato
plant apparently referenced on Day 94 of
Chris's diary are not as botanists have
long believed harmless but are in fact
poisonous under the right circumstances
he's thrown plenty of theories around
over the years and most have been
disproved but in 2015 he published a
study that claimed to have found
elevated levels of the anti-metabolite
elkinavini in Sample seeds gathered from
the site of the boss the study
ultimately concluded that consumption of
these seeds very likely contributed to
Christopher's death
anyway poison aside if you've read into
the wild or seen the film adaptation
there's a good chance you think of
Christopher McCandless as an idealist
who should be admired for his courage
and principles but not everybody views
him that way in fact there are plenty of
people who see Chris as an arrogant
idiot who got himself killed thanks to a
woeful lack of understanding of what he
was getting himself into
as uncharitable as that hot take may
seem there's no denying that Chris was
somewhat unprepared for his final
Adventure I've already mentioned that he
tried to hike back to civilization two
months into his trip before being
thwarted by the swollen tetlankia River
what I didn't mention is that just 800
meters Downstream from his attempted
crossing point was a hand-operated cable
car that would have allowed him to cross
the river with ease if he'd a map with
him
he'd have known that and he would quite
possibly still be alive today ultimately
there's probably a kernel of Truth in
both viewpoints but whatever your
feelings towards the man who called
himself Alexander Supertramp
it's hard not to admire his
single-minded determination to live the
life he wanted to live most of us follow
the pathways laid out before us by
society and the expectations of our
families and friends without ever really
questioning it and we all know plenty of
people who diligently work away at
careers they don't particularly like so
they can afford to buy things they never
want nor need Christopher McCandless saw
our obsession with money status success
and material things and just rejected it
he didn't want a career
he wanted a life and he didn't need
things he craved experiences
it's funny to think that Chris walked
into the wild in what many of us would
have considered to have been a simpler
time a time before the internet had
wormed its way into every corner of our
lives and before we carried smartphones
in our pockets
so you could say his message is more
relevant today than it's ever been
before
and that's probably why his story
continues to speak to people even today
years after his death
thanks for watching